millennials don't conform to traditional
political stereotypes there are social
liberals and fiscal centrists they're
pro-business and they're pro-government
however their support for government
action has been overblown in the media
let's walk through this first they like
business a majority of Millennials say
they themselves would like to start
their own business one day they're
favorable towards profit and competition
and they strongly prefer a free-market
system over a government managed economy
however Millennials came of a
politically impressionable age during or
shortly after the Great Recession and
the ensuing sluggish economy has left a
third of them under or unemployed and a
third are living at home with their
parents consequently many of them are
uncertain as to whether the free market
system drives their own income mobility
and it's likely that this uncertainty
has bolstered their support for
government action that being said
Millennials also realize that government
comes with its own problems for instance
sixty-six percent say that government is
usually wasteful and inefficient this is
up 20 points from where it stood in 2009
two-thirds also think that government
regulators when they write and enforce
regulations usually favor special
interests over the public interests and
then fully fifty-eight percent of
Millennials say the government agencies
generally abuse their power we also find
that as Millennials make more money and
pay more in taxes their support for
income redistribution steadily declines
for instance among Millennials making
less than twenty thousand dollars a year
a majority support income redistribution
however once Millennials make forty
thousand dollars a year or more support
flips and a majority oppose income
redistribution what these data indicate
is that Millennials become more fiscally
conservative as they age pay more in
taxes and take on more responsibilities
however many of these responsibilities
are being delayed for this cohort we
find that they were getting married
later buying homes later and starting
families when they're older but these
life experiences will eventually occur
and when they do we could find this
cohort to be
supportive of government action than
they were in their youth
you